und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian sieers ihn allen
einen guten Sonntagabend Zuversicht das
ist ungefähr das Allerletzte was einem
in Zusammenhang mit der Lage in narost
einfallen würde aber heute gibt es
zuversichtliche Stimmen von israelischen
offiziellen und von Mittelsmännern in
Qatar die Fortschritte sehen in den
mühsamen ver
zur Befreiung der Geiseln aus der Hand
der Hamas dabei soll es auch um 5 Tage
Feuerpause gehen für die Menschen in
Gaza von denen aber tausende auf der
Flucht sind und nicht mehr wissen wohin
aktuell ist davon allerdings noch nichts
zu erleben im Gegenteil aus Tel Aviv
Henriette de
mier der Wind zerrt an den Zelten an dem
bisschen zur Hause welches sich die
Menschen in diesem Lager inunis bauen
konnten seit heute regnet es die Not der
Menschen die hierher geflüchtet sind
wird immer
größer sie haben uns Decken gegeben um
unsere Kinder zuecken aber sie sehen ja
selbst im Zelt ist es nass alle werden
krank wir wissen nicht was wir machen
sollen das Wasser dringt ein es ist kalt
wir haben Hunger unsere Betten sind
nass währenddessen weitet das
israelische Militär seinen Einsatz im
gazreifen aus um weitere
hamasterroristen aufzuspüren am
Wochenende waren bei einem Angriff in
der Stadt ranonis nach
Krankenhausangaben mindestens 47
Menschen getötet worden unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht im
alschifer Krankenhaus konnten sich heute
Mitarbeiter der WHO ein Bild der Lage
machen es sei eine Todeszone sie hätten
ein Massengrab gesehen in dem 80
Menschen begraben sein sollen
Anerkennung für die
Mediziner das ist Albtraum für sie aber
wie Sie wissen ist das alles komplex und
wir geben unser Bestes als
Gesundheitsexperte bin ich absolut
überwältigt von ihrer Arbeit ihre
Bemühungen hier sind heldenhaft und
machen mich
sprachlos die noch verbliebenen
Patienten sollen so schnell wie möglich
herausgebracht werden 31 Säuglinge
konnten mit Hilfe der WHO inzwischen
evakuiert werden sie wurden in den Süden
nach Raffa gebracht innenpolitisch
steigt der Druck auf israels Regierung
mehr zu tun damit die über 230 Geiseln
der Hamas freikommen Qatar kommt dabei
eine Schlüsselrolle zu der
Ministerpräsident des Emirates gibt sich
beim Treffen mit dem EU
außenbeauftragten
optimistisch ich bin jetzt
zuversichtlicher dass wir nah genug sind
um eine Einigung zu erzielen die die
Menschen sicher nach Hause zurückbringen
kann ein Deal um die Geiseln
zurückzubekommen Details und
bedingungenb es dazu bisher
nicht wir hoffen dass wir in den
nächsten Tagen eine beträchtliche Anzahl
von Geiseln freiekommen können ich
möchte nicht auf die Einzelheiten dieser
Gespräche eingehen sie sind
offensichtlich sehr
heikel am Abend dann veröffentlichte das
israelische Militär Bilder eines Tunnels
auf dem Gelände des alschifer
Krankenhauses 10 m unter der Erde ein 55
m langer Tunnel der Hamas wofür er genau
genutzt
ist noch
unklar Andreas Krieg ist Militärexperte
mit Fachgebiet Nahost am Kings College
in London und jetzt bei uns danke dass
Sie bei uns sind Herr Krieg und guten
Abend guten Abend stehen wir denn
tatsächlich kurz vor einem Abkommen zur
Freilassung von Geiseln oder sagen Sie
im Nahen Osten wo nichts geht und alles
möglich ist sollte man niemals zu früh
zu zuversichtlich
sein das stimmt aber wir sind ja schon
seit fast dre vier Wochen dran
Zuversicht zu zeigen und die Kataris
sagen auch von ihrer Seite her dass man
immer näher an einem Deal dran ist
vor allem zwischen den Israelis und der
Hamas war es am Anfang relativ schwierig
zu demem Einkommen zu dem Vereinbarung
zu kommen aber was wir jetzt sehen ist
dass die großen Schlüsselprobleme die
großen Fragen geklärt sein sollen es
sind eher die kleinen logistischen
Probleme die jetzt am die jetzt noch
gegen Ende ein bisschen Probleme machen
aber von dem was ich aus Qatar höre von
dem was ich auch aus den USA und aus
Israel höre ist man glaube ich relativ
nah dran an einer zumindest ein
teilweisen Freilassung der Geiseln dann
lassen Sie uns über die militärische
Lage bitte reden kann man sagen den
Norden von Gaza hat Israel jetzt unter
Kontrolle und nimmt jetzt verstärkt den
Süden ins
Visier nee so einfach ist es nicht also
wir sehen ja dass die Israelis sehr gute
Fortschritte gemacht haben zumindest in
den Außenbezirken von Gaza Stadt aber
sie sind noch nicht tief in den in das
Zentrum von gasastadt vorgedrungen wo
wirklich die heftigen Kämpfe auf sie
warten was wir auch nicht vergessen
dürfen ist es gibt ja das Schlachtfeld
oberirdisch und es gibt aber auch ein
unterirdisches Schlachtfeld wo Israel
noch gar nicht dran teilgenommen hat und
die Hamas momentan mehr oder weniger wie
Geister aus dem Nichts erscheinen und
dann auch wieder verschwinden durch
diese extrem langen Tunnelsysteme reden
von hunderten von Kilometern von Tunnel
die manchmal dutzende Meter tief unter
der Erde sind unter der gesamten Stadt
da hat Israel überhaupt noch keine
Fortschritte gemacht und wir sehen auch
dass die Israelis sehr langsam nur
vorkommen wirklich ein Häuserkampf Haus
um Haus äh und da wird sich zeigen welch
wie die schwierigen Kämpfe in den
nächsten Tagen aussehen und wie weit
Israel da wirklich Fortschritte machen
kann und danach wird sich erst zeigen in
wie weit man dann vielleicht das noch
ausweiten kann in den Süden was wir auf
jeden Fall jetzt schon sehen ist eine
wirklich riesige Flüchtlingsbewegung wir
haben es gerade im Film auch gesehen von
Menschen die fragen wohin sollen wir
noch wir sehen auch viele Tote unter der
Zivilbevölkerung Israels Premierminister
Netanyahu sagt ja selbst wir wollen die
Zivilbevölkerung schützen aber wir sind
dabei nicht erfolgreich warum eigentlich
nicht n gut wir müssen erstmal anfangen
und sagen sicherlich operiert die Hamas
aus der Zivilbevölkerung heraus das geht
natürlich auch gar nicht anders wenn man
sich die
das Schlachtfeld mal anschaut also es
sind ja im Endeffekt sind das eine
extrem dicht besiedelte Stadt aus der
der Hamas wo die Hamas operiert wo die
meisten Institutionen sowohl zivil als
auch militärisch extrem nah beieinander
liegen gleichzeitig haben die Israelis
und das ist sehr wichtig beim
humanitären Völkerrecht dass man guckt
äh dass man natürlich unterscheidet
zwischen kom anen und Zivilisten und da
haben sollte man eigentlich wenn man in
ein wenn man nicht wirklich sich
hundertprozentig sicher ist sollte man
immer im Sinne der Zivilisten
entscheiden die Israelis haben leider in
den letzten Wochen sehr oft gegen
Zivilisten entschieden und das gemacht
was sie im Endeffekt am besten finden um
militärische Ziele auszustalten und das
ist halt oft sehr fragwürdig gewesen
viele Analysten international sagen auch
da hat Israel oft zu harsch gehandelt
und vor allem unverhältnismäßig
gehandelt die 13 000 toten Zivilisten
sprechen auf jeden Fall dafür es ist
eine sehr schwierige Situation äh und
deswegen muss es jetzt auch erstmal eine
humanitäre Pause geben israel muss auch
ganz klar noch mal aus westlicher Sicht
gesagt werden dass sie nicht handeln
können in einem Vakuum sondern sie
müssen das Völkerrecht sowohl auch
humanitär natürlich berücksichtigen und
vor allem ähäh bei der aussuchung bei
der bei der aussuchung der Ziele vor
allem aufpassen dass sie Ziele suchen
die im Endeffekt nicht so viele
Zivilisten töten jetzt sagt aber Israel
wir haben das Recht uns zu verteidigen
wir müssen Hamas militärisch schlagen
gäbe es also aus ihrer Sicht einen
anderen Weg für Israel Hamas militärisch
tatsächlich ja endgültig zu
vernichten nein also es ist eine
Illusion
dass man was wir müssen das ja als als
als eine Bewegung sehen die Hamas ist
eine Bewegung das ist ein Aufstand und
in der Aufstandsbekämpfung braucht man
primär ein strategisch und ein
politisches Ziel bevor man überhaupt
militärische Macht anwendet das Problem
ist dass die israelische Armee in einem
Vakuum alleine gelassen wird von der
politischen Führung weil es keine
politische Strategie gibt es gibt keine
politische Strategie für was man am
Boden erreichen will es gibt aber auch
ganz besonders keine politische
Strategie was man nach der Eroberung von
gazastadt überhaupt machen will fakt ist
die Idee äh dieser Bewegung der hamast
lässt sich nicht einfach militärisch
schlagen und da ist es extrem wichtig
dass westliche Länder Druck ausüben auf
Israel zu sagen was wollt ihr eigentlich
erreichen wie wollt ihr es erreichen und
wie können wir einen Frieden schaffen
der wirklich langfristig ist und dafür
gehört es einfach dazu dass man die zwei
St Lösung und vor allem die Ursache
dieses Konfliktes näher angeht und dass
die Israelis sich mit den Palästinensern
wieder an einen Tisch setzen sie haben
es gerade schon kurz angedeutet gegen
eine Terrororganisation kann man mit
Soldaten Vorgehen gegen Ideologie in den
Köpfen sind Soldaten machtlos wie groß
ist denn jetzt die Gefahr angesichts
dieser großen zivilen Verluste dieser
vielen Toten dass der Hass noch viel
größer
wird nun das muss man halt differenziert
betrachten natürlich darf man auch nicht
vergessen das was im Gazastreifen
passiert passiert ja auch
gleichzeitig auch im Westjordanland also
die Besatzung in Westjordanland gehört
ja auch Teil zu diesem Konflikt und was
sehr interessant ist was wir sehen ist
dass natürlich auch Zivilisten in Gaza
immer mehr natürlich auch die Hamas
rannehmen und sagen ihr seid auch daran
schuld dass wir in dieser Tragödie sind
wenn man unfragen sich anschaut so ist
es so dass die Leute in Gaza mehr und
mehr antihamas werden werend die Leute
im Westjordanland die sich von der
Palästinenserbehörde alleine gelassen
fühlen immer mehr ProAm werden was wir
auf jeden Fall sagen können ist dass der
flir auch für die Leute in Gaza die
jetzt vielleicht antihamas werden auf
jeden Fall nicht pro Israel werden und
da ist das große Problem bei der
ausstandsbekäm Bekämpfung dass man vor
allem in die Köpfe der Menschen kommen
dass Israel sich zeigt als jemand der
auch Interesse und Empathie zeigt den
Palästinensern gegenüber und dass man
vor allem eine politische Alternative
zur Hamas bietet und das ist eben im
momentan nicht der Fall und so kann
Aufstandsbekämpfung niemals
funktionieren und natürlich ist sie eine
terroristische Organisation aber es ist
eine terroristische Organisation die in
einer auf in einer Aufstandsbewegung
eingeflochten ist und so muss man also
auch gucken dass man die Leute
abholt und das passiert halt in Israel
momentan überhaupt nicht sagt Andreas
Krieg Militärexperte Fachgebiet na
aostam Kings College in London Herr
Krieg vielen Dank für ihre Expertise
heute Abend bei
uns gerne eine reguläre Armee also gegen
eine Terrororganisation das nennt man
asymmetrische Kriegsführung oder
einfacher gesagt die Terroristen von
Hamas wollen keinen Krieg gewinnen
sondern die Sympathien der Palästinenser
und der arabischen Welt Israel weiß
genau dass es auch einen Kampf führt um
die internationale öffentliche Meinung
bei der Armee im Außenministerium in
Jerusalem und in Israels Botschaften
weltweit beschäftigen sich ganze
Abteilungen exakt damit und dennoch
scheint es gerade so als würde Israel
diesen Teil des Krieges verlieren
Florian jetzt mit dem Beispiel Belgien
das für weitere Länder in Europa
steht diese Geschichte kann z.Bp hier
beginnen in vervier Ostbelgien die Stadt
hat 55 000 Einwohner bis auf das Rathaus
wenig zu bieten für Touristen und sie
hat im Sommer schon alle Beziehungen zu
Israel gekappt per
Stadtratsbeschluss wir haben den Krieg
Russlands gegen die ukra
verteil
IG in China und so weiter und so konnten
wir zur Situation in den
palästinensischen Gebieten nicht weiter
Schweigen kleiner Schönheitsfehler
vervier hatte nie Beziehungen zu Israel
der boott ist also bloß symbolisch aber
er steht für eine Stimmung in Belgien
erst recht nach
Kriegsbeginn es ist Zeit für Sanktionen
gegen Israel sagt zuletzt die
stellvertretende Ministerpräsidentin von
den Grünen und bekm nicht etwa heftige
Kritik sondern Unterstützung sogar von
Christdemokraten natürlich liegen
Sanktionen gegen Israel auf dem Tisch
auch ein Verfahren vor dem
Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof meine Partei hat dem
belgischen Parlament dazu bereits einen
Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt noch bremst die mitregierende
liberale Partei aber die Idee trifft
eine Stimmung solidaritätsdemos mit
Israel sucht man hier vergebens solche
mit Palästinensern gibt es jeden Abend
wie hier in Brüssel wo uns ein
Demonstrant anspricht er habe da eine
Botschaft auch an die
deutschen wenn Deutschland nicht in der
Lage ist zwischen seinen Fehlern in der
Geschichte und jenen von Israel heute zu
unterscheiden dann ist das eine Schande
für
Deutschland es ist in diesen Tagen
vermutlich oft schwierig Israel zu
repräsentieren vielleicht in Belgien ein
bisschen mehr die israelische
Botschafterin sucht nach
Erklärungen in Belgien wird in SE
Monaten gewählt und manche Parteien
wollen sich wohl profilieren als
Unterstützer des palästinensischen
Volkes und sie kommen dann mit
Initiativen die inakzeptabel
sind einerseits hat Belgien eine große
muslimische Minderheit andererseits sagt
der Politikwissenschaftler Dave sinade
versuche das Land schon immer alle
Seiten unter einen Hut zu kriegen auch
im eigenen
Land Belgien ist ein Land das seit
langem Kompromisse finden muss zwischen
verschiedenen politischen Standpunkten
aber vor allem zwischen den
verschiedenen sprach und
Bevölkerungsgruppen des Landes das führt
dazu dass Belgien in internationalen
Konflikten immer eine Haltung einnimmt
die nach Konsens sucht und so ist es aus
sichichtte einen ein vermittelnder
neutraler Standpunkt den viele in
Belgien einnehmen aus Sicht anderer
einseitiges Ergreifen einer Partei es
hängt immer von der Perspektive
ab zu diesem und allen anderen Themen
hält sie die ZDF heute App auf dem
neuesten Stand jetzt auch bei Whatsapp
scannen Sie dafür einfach den hier
angezeigten QR-Code oder abonnieren Sie
uns direkt bei Whatsapp selbst die
Nachrichtenlage kompakt zusammengefasst
mit den Updates am Morgen und am Abend
und das nachrichtenupdate hier im
heutejournal jetzt von dir
Gund bei einer Gedenkstunde zum
Volkstrauertag im Bundestag hat
Schwedens Kronprinzessin Victoria das
Leid der Kriege in narost und in der
Ukraine betont die Stimmung in der Welt
sei so eisig wie seit langem nicht
mehr die groß angelegte russische
Invasion in der Ukraine bedroht den
Frieden auf unserem gesamten Kontinent
erschüttert die Grundfesten der
Weltordnung und für sagt unermessliches
menschliches Leid es ist ein Krieg der
uns an die dunkelsten Kapitel der
europäischen Geschichte
erinnert um diefer von Bundespräsident
Steinmeier sprach das traditionelle
Totengedenken gemeinsam mit
Kronprinzessin Victoria gedachte er wie
alljährlich viele am Volkstrauertag der
Opfer von Gewaltherrschaft und
Krieg und in der Ukraine dauern die
Kämpfe an nach eigenen Angaben ist es
der ukrainischen Armee gelungen die
russischen Streitkräfte am Fluss nipro
in der Südukraine einige Kilometer
zurückzudrängen zugleich setzt das
russische Militär seine Angriffe auf
viele Orte in der Ukraine fort Ziel war
erneut auch die Hauptstadt Kiev laut
ukrainischer Luftabwehr wurde ein
Großteil der Drohnen zerstört in
zahlreichen Regionen gab es nach den
jüngsten russischen Angriffswellen
keinen Strom inmitten einer schweren
Wirtschaftskrise haben die Argentinier
einen neuen Präsidenten gewählt mit
Ergebnissen wird in den nächsten Stunden
gerechnet der Stichwahl stellten sich
der linke bisherige Wirtschaftsminister
Massa und der Politik Neuling may der
sich selbst einen
anarchokapitalisten nennt in Umfragen
lagen beide fast gleich auf in dem
einstreichen Argentinien leben rund 40%
der Menschen in Armut die liegt bei mehr
als
140% weltweit weniger Plastikmüll an
diesem Ziel arbeiten die Vereinten
Nationen in mehreren Verhandlungsrunden
in Kenias Hauptstadt Nairobi haben
Vertreter aus mehr als 170 Staaten
einwöchige Beratungen dazu beendet bis
2025 soll ein rechtlich verbindliches
UN-Abkommen gegen die Vermüllung von
Umwelt und Meeren stehen denn immer noch
gelangen jedes Jahr Millionen Tonnen
Plastik in die Ökosysteme und Schaden
somit Lebensräumen und
Gesundheit zum Abschluss ihres
Bundesparteitages in Augsburg hat die
Linke weitere Kandidaten für die
Europawahl im Juni kommmenden Jahres
bestimmt die mehr als 400 Delegierten
setzten insgesamt 20 Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten auf die Liste bereits gestern
wurde ein vierköpfiges Spitzenteam um
den Bundesvorsitzenden Martin
schirdewann gekürt bei der letzten
Europawahl 2019 hatte die Linke
5,5% der Stimmen und 5 Mandate
erreicht wenn diese Klage erfolgreich
ist würde das Deutschland
wirtschaftspolitisch wirklich hart
treffen wahrscheinlich so hart dass wir
das nicht bestehen werden hat
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert habbeck
im Bundestag gesagt das war im Juni und
da war noch nicht klar dass diese Klage
tatsächlich Erfolg reich sein würde
jetzt ist sie erfolgreich das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat der
Bundesregierung einen 60 Milliarden Teil
ihrer Finanzierungspläne um die Ohren
gehauen und jetzt stellt sich die Frage
ob habck Recht hatte mit seiner
Prophezeiung das wir das nicht bestehen
werden und wen er genau meint mit wir
die deutschen allgemein oder seine
Bundesregierung nächste Woche geht es
noch mal um den Haushalt und die Frage
woher sollen die Euros kommen
frankbuchwald sparen aber wo noch lässt
die Ampel sich nicht in die Karten
schauen heute aber wagt der
Finanzminister sich aus der Deckung
kurzfristig sein die Folgen des
Karlsruher Urteils zwar hart so Lindner
im Zeitungsinterview langfristig aber
könne Deutschland sich Chancen
erarbeiten wir werden jetzt gezwungen
mit weniger öffentlichen Subventionen
die Wirtschaft zu modernisieren es geht
jetzt um weniger Bürokratie agilere
Verwaltung technikfreundlichkeit und die
Mobilisierung privaten Kapitals für
Investitionen weniger Subventionen das
trifft vor allem das grüngführte
Wirtschaftsministerium der Umbau der
Energieversorgung wärmewende Klimaschutz
alles milliardenprojekte die Vorsitzende
der Grünen in Berlin direkt Interview
deshalb wenig begeistert wir sollten
nicht entscheiden dass Arbeitsplätze
zwar geschaffen werden aber außerhalb
von Deutschland geschaffen werden und
wir sollten vor allen gucken dass unsere
Finanzpolitik nicht am Ende zu einer
innovationsbremse und damit auch zu
einer wettbew igkeitbremse wird wenig
Begeisterung auch beim Koalitionspartner
SPD die Sozialdemokraten sehen Lindners
Vorschlag kritisch sie setzen eher auf
mehr Einnahmen wir haben uns aber im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass wir
auch klimaschädliche Subventionen
abbauen wollen und wenn die
Einnahmenseite adressiert ist reden wir
auch gerne darüber wie wir die
verbessern können beispielsweise indem
wir die vermögensten 5% vermögensten
diesem Land stärker zur
Krisenbewältigung heranziehen können das
klingt bei der linken Opposition ganz
ähnlich der Haushalt der Ampel sei
bereits jetzt ein Sparhaushalt weitere
Einschnitte etwa bei Sozialausgaben kaum
vorstellbar das ist ja total
kontraproduktiv wir müssen nicht weiter
kürzen kürzen kürzen sondern wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die dringen
notwendigen Aufgaben auch finanziert
sind und das kann man nur tun durch
hohere steuern und die Überwindung der
Schuldenbremse alles keine guten Ideen
findet die Union weitere Belastungen für
die Wirtschaft etwa durch höhere Steuern
setzten das falsche Signal wir haben
mittlerweile 4 Millionen Menschen im
Bürgergeld die erwerbsfähig sind die
also arbeiten könnten und es wäre
natürlich eine Riesenaufgabe für den
Arbeitsminister huberto Heil wenn er
davon mal tatsächlich welche in
Beschäftigung brechte wenn eine Million
also nur jeder vierte aus dieser Gruppe
tatsächlich eine Arbeit aufnehmen würde
würde das etwa 30 Milliarden mehr
Einnahmen für den Bund bringen
schwierige politische Entscheidungen die
den ampelpartnern viel Abfall langen
dürften nicht wenige sehen die Koalition
bereits vor einer Zerreißprobe dabei hat
die verteilungsdiskussion noch gar nicht
richtig angefangen und so könnte der
Berliner Herbst am Ende doch noch
ziemlich heiß
werden so jetzt der sonntagssport mit
Gundula aber du hast erst noch einen
Blick
zurück die Polizei in Berlin teilte mit
dass bei den Ausschreitungen rund um das
Fußball Länderspiel gestern gegen die
Türkei 92 Personen festgenommen worden
sind und für türkischen Fans habe es
aggressives Verhalten gegeben dazu sein
Auseinandersetzungen mit deutschen Fans
gekommen mehrere Menschen seinen
verletzt worden auch zwei Einsatzkräfte
der Polizei 71 Strafermittlungsverfahren
seien eingeleitet worden und morgen
reist das dfbteam nach Wien wo am
Dienstagabend der nächste em-test
ansteht nach dem 2:3 gegen die Türkei
wird sich Bundestrainer nagelsmann am
Nachmittag zu möglichen Änderungen in
der Aufstellung äußern das ZDF überträgt
am das Spiel am Dienstagabend ab
20:15
Uhr Tennisprofi Novak dokovic hat die
ATP Finals in Turin gewonnen der
serbische Weltranglisten erste setzte
sich im Endspiel mit 6:3 und 6:3 gegen
den italienischen Publikumsliebling
Jannick Sinner durch für dokovic ist es
bereits der siebte Titel bei diesem
Saison
Abschlussturnier Formel 1 Weltmeister
Max Verstappen hat auch den Großen Preis
von Las Vegas gewonnen auf dem Stadtkurs
verwies der Red Bull Pilot Charles
Claire im Ferrari auf Rang 2 dritter
wurde der Mexikaner Sergio Perz
ebenfalls im Red Bull für Verstappen ist
es der 18 Saisonsieg im 21 Rennen Bob
Rennfahrer Johannes Lochner hat mit dem
dritten Sieg im dritten Saisonrennen ein
perfektes erst Weltcup Wochenende
gefeiert auf der Olympiabahn im
chinesischen young King ließ der
33-Jährige im vierbob seinem
Dauerrivalen Francesco Friedrich wie
schon an den beiden Tagen zuvor keine
Chance zweiter wurde überraschend der
starke Italiener Patrick Baumgartner vor
Rekordweltmeister Friedrich aus
Sachsen eine
harschträne von Napoleon ein Taschentuch
Handschuh und ein Hemd sind jetzt
versteigert worden am meisten brachte
ein alter Filzhut des französischen
Kaisers ein
1,93 Millionen Euro laut Auktionshaus
ist das Weltrekord für Napoleons
Filzhüte gleichzeitig ist es Zeichen wie
sehr der Mann die Fantasie beflügelt
auch über 200 Jahre nach seinem Tod und
das wird sich nicht ändern im Gegenteil
in Frankreich macht ein Napoleon Film
forore den Altmeister Scott gedreht hat
ein Brite für ein giganto Budget von 130
Millionen da hätte man haufenweise
Filzhüte kaufen können Napoleon im Kino
der macht genauso verfallen wie einer
Frau aus Paris Thomas
waldeter Stellung
auf Napoleon der Feldherr der Eroberer
monumental wird es und
laut dort seinen Napoleon in die
Schlacht
schickt und was treibt den Mann eine
Frau legt zumindest der filmnahe
Josephine
dene wenn du runter guckst wirst du eine
Überraschung
[Musik]
sehen es gibt tausende Bücher über
Napoleon aber nur ein paar Dutzend über
Josephin man liest zur Vorbereitung
alles was man kann man lernt wie er wohl
war und wie es wohl war mit ihm gewesen
zu sein man lernt alles über
französische
Geschichte die war demnach vor allem
blutig sehr
blutig so zeigt der Film Napoleon bei
der Enthauptung Marie antoineetz da sei
aber nicht gewesen sagt ein Historiker
der den Film gesehen hat erfindet
schneidende
Worte als Historiker ist man extrem
enttäuscht dieser Film hat weder Hand
noch Fuß keine Ähnlichkeit mit der
Geschichte der Film ist schlechtig und
vulgär das Gegenteil dessen was man von
Napoleon
weiß ein Urteil fast so brutal wie der
Film wir fragen den Regisseur was er
darauf
antwortet kümmer dich um deinen Kram
echt
jetzt wenn ich recherchiere gucke ich
wer der Mann gewesen sein könnte viele
Bücher sagen dazu nichts wenn ich eine
Geschichte erzähle dann will ich nicht
nur Schlachten zeigen und Politik denn
das wäre langweilig eine
Geschichtsstunde helassen so erfährt man
aus dem Film denn auch wenig darüber
warum Frankreich Napoleon noch immer auf
den söckel stellt dass er bis heute
fortwirkt mit dem ersten Gesetzbuch dem
Aufbau der öffentlichen Verwaltung der
Ehrenlegion bei dem als Weltpremiere
angekündigten Schaulaufen in Paris war
die Sprache des Abends wie auch sonst
bei dieser Hollywood Produktion Englisch
selbst bei den wenigen französischen
Darstellern der Film zeigt dass wir noch
schöne epische Filme und
Liebesgeschichten machen können mit
Schlachten und
so und schönen Kostümen und so Ridley
Scott setzt seinem Napoleon die Krone
auf nicht dem den die Franzosen aus
ihrer Geschichte
kennen Napoleon bei uns ab Donnerstag im
im Kino so das war schon mal ein kleiner
Vorausblick ein wichtiges
innenpolitisches Thema der kommenden
Woche haben wir mit den heftigen
haushaltsdiskussionen vorhin ja auch
schon gehört jetzt kommen die anderen
auf die wir ebenfalls gucken werden der
heute journal Ausblick von Carolina
[Musik]
Freitag die Niederlande werden wieder
wählen nach nur zweieinhalb Jahren im
Sommer war die Koalition um Langzeit
Regierungschef rütte zerbrochen
die Wahl am Mittwoch verspricht Spannung
es gibt neue Spitzenkandidaten und neue
Parteien mit Aussicht auf
Regierungsbeteiligung und am Ende wird
es einen neuen Ministerpräsidenten geben
oder eine
Ministerpräsidentin klimaschädliche
Treibhausgase reduzieren CO2 aus der
Luft herausfiltern und Medizintechnik
durch künstliche Intelligenz kompakter
und kostengünstiger machen mit diesen
Themen gehen drei Projekte in den
Wettbewerb um den diesjährigen Deutschen
Zukunfts pris am Mittwoch wird
Bundespräsident Steinmeier die
bedeutende wissenschaftsauszeichnung
verleihen Haushaltsloch ampelkrise
Migrationspolitik es ist mächtig Dampf
im Kessel der Grünen Basis Parteispitze
und Grüne Minister stehen unter Druck
kann ein gemeinsamer neustaat auf dem
Bundesparteitag gelingen ab Donnerstag
wird
debattiert und das Herbstwetter in der
neuen Woche bleibt überwiegend
regnerisch und stürmisch Morgen zeigt
sich südlich der Donau auch häufiger die
Sonne sonst bleibt es eher trüb mit
Regen bei 9 bis 12° dazu weht der Wind
an den Küsten stürmisch um Ost in den
nächsten Tagen fällt Regen aber die
Sonne kommt immer mal wieder durch am
Donnerstag wird es stürmisch und auch
kühler 0 bis
12° so morgen freuen sich hier Maria
taslomka und Heinz Wolf auf sie und um
25 gibt es später noch eine heute
Express von uns allen in Redaktion
Produktion da drüben in der Regie und
natürlich auch von uns hier im Studio
ein angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss